cuáles son los escenarios más
preocupantes
bueno lo que realmente nos preocupa en
amnistía internacional es que esta pena
se está aplicando a personas que
muchísimas veces no han tenido juicios
justos y además han tenido que firmar
una confesión entre comillas después de
haber sido torturados esto es una enorme
preocupación que tenemos en nuestra en
nuestra organización
pensamos que la pena de muerte tiene que
acabar en el mundo lo vamos a conseguir
en los años que llevamos desde
1977 cuando sólo 16 países en el mundo
habían abolido la pena de muerte ya hay
144 y hay buenas tendencias la
preocupación es que hay más de 28 mil
personas en el mundo hoy por hoy que
esperan su muerte condenados por el
estado no queda poco tiempo pero no
quiero dejar de realizar la siguiente
pregunta porque si bien las cifras
alarman no de cierta manera contrastan
de manera positiva por llamarlo de
alguna forma con la 2010 no a qué
atribuye esta tendencia además de la
pandemia del cobi 19
bueno el hecho de que se hayan retomado
los juicios a un ritmo más normal
como ha dicho ustedes es un factor
importante hay una cierta tendencia a
utilizar la pena de muerte cada vez más
en delitos comunes como por ejemplo
posesión posesión y tráfico de drogas
esto es algo realmente preocupante el
número de condenas va en aumento como
ustedes han citado las cifras y esto
significa que puede ejecutarse pueden
ser ejecutadas más personas
lo que tenemos que conseguir en
cualquier caso es alzar nuestra voz e
invitó al público a mirar los casos que
tenemos abiertos en nuestro sitio web
estoy segura de que a la larga lo
conseguiremos